mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
alles restlos wünschen ihnen viel
vergnügen
es schreibt der reflektiert mein name
ist spitze liegen die herkunft oder wenn
man schon mal drüber reden
bestiegen sportics bürgertum bz wenn
nicht sogar europas politiker rauen und
wenn es nach uns geht macht man der reis
du jetzt hat die hypothek auf der club-
oder
wir kommen nach dem kulturplatz ja unser
thema heute ist das erben einfach
unvorstellbar 100 milliarden franken
werden alleine dieses jahr in der
schweiz vererbt da ist es nicht weiter
erstaunlich dass es bei so viel geld
auch richtig viel knatsch gibt zu diesem
thema hat autor und schauspieler mike
müller soeben ein neues stück
geschrieben das hier im miller's studio
in zürich aufgeführt wird er ihn treffen
wir gleich zum gespräch
was heißt das neue stück erbs auch
während der pandemie geschrieben wie bis
auf dem tech das thema nicht alleine th
immer dankbar mehr qualität bis zebra
viele vorteile über familie über das
land über soziologie über die herkunft
und haut über mies ist auch comedien
buch zur dieses typs das viel
recherchiert wie das thema da hat sie
auch wahnsinnig viel personal und
unglaublich viel klischee ist das beste
was passieren zumal
die ja gut für die kritischen stimmen
werden bis das funktional ist und
familie sei immer das funktional und die
funktionalität und die besucher richtig
böse zum vorschein für mehr als
berechtigt
das spiel schon wieder alle rollen
selbst glaubt dass man es war für mich
natürlich auf 86 rief es ist einfacher
wenn man nicht auch so lange im
möglichkeit mit den beats und akute not
und brauche 50 uhr
gretchen mit den annahmen ist im armen
sie bitten die vorsitzende richterin
verteidiger verhandlung aber es sind
battaglia panzer heißer und heißer
es geht um der plastik von verstorbener
karl-heinz senior geboren am dritten
instanz 180 kinder bag verstorben am 6 c
22 sekunden ins noble blind
versteht eine geschwister findige
anwälte und ja auch das langenthaler
geschehe es geht um etwas bei der app
sache eine typisch müller von menschen
[Musik]
das mini beide brüder einfach das namen
wiener bass und darum ist renault
handgriffen wird aus verschmutzten
flächen für vermied setzte giorgio jetzt
gemerkt dass du erfahrung um zwei brüder
cash wo das testament auf den tisch
schlagen ist heftig pflege heftig der
papi hat noch niemals chf lag ein kann
sie mini beide berührten schon mit der
patientenverfügung von papi im büro vom
zentrumsleiter gestattet wir haben ein
studio stieg sie durch die erzählung
fahrt minister aktiver kümmert und
therapie sind die sachen zusammen
amüsiert
dass die britin rosie drehen die
akademie
socken ssl finke und
johannesgasse erste frau richterin
stoffen eben im blut
je länger gestritten wird umso weniger
geht's um den schnöden mammon hier wird
abgerechnet alle schmähungen jeder liebe
setzen alles verheimlichte kommt im
angesicht des todes auf den tisch es ist
aber so dass
amerika
springfield und das konnten die mutig
sie bezirks wies der papi hätte eine
frau astrid kommt kauft in florida
müller schoss ihr zu vergehen zwischen
den charakteren
legt algier alle eifersüchteleien mit
verstand und punktgenau am humorfrei wie
blöd die flach angriff des kammerspiel
die händler vorlagen ich will sie das
verständlich als gutes bedeuten die
trauermusik of their grad
plus
[Musik]
der zaster hält die menschen in seinen
bann und offenbart uhr menschliches die
liebe familie ist das eigentlich schwere
[Musik]
familie graf von krockow tropischer
vorzeichen der fotos ist gestorben jetzt
geht's ans verteilen
ist fronleichnam und wir nach der
politik ein abdanken
aber das größte geschenk das haben wir
ja schon lange führen
und auf das sollte kein land und kein
kondom erbschaftssteuer
rosa fußnote verrät
was ich sowieso gut
100 prozentige erbschaftssteuern
ist ja nicht anders aus gratis- gleich
gibt's nur noch mal mit abschreibungen
und mit einer hundertprozentigen
erbschaftsteuer damals ja die un hätten
einfach war nur interessant
und lea büscher hertie war ich am ende
stirbt der nächste
und die app traumata ziehen schon neue
kreise
[Musik]
als viel spannendes personal in dem
stück vieh nach ist das an der realität
tiroler richter
also schön recherchierte bio vor gericht
sie also im gericht nicht vor gericht
was man korrekt wie es sei
auch die glut wie storage merkt dass das
verliert sie aber eine sich aus fiktion
also immer ein unterhaltsamer und das
material literatur aber ich meine es
geht nicht da oder tier richterin
sondern das ist faktisch bereits
menschen die haben
wir sind dinge erfahrung ich sehe also
wahrscheinlich zehn zieht hof bands
dafür was hat mit genauso für dich ja
erstens das natürlich einfache
bevölkerung plex ist dass ich mein
tag bei mir bin immer nur über die
eigene die schicht nach und große magie
für komplizierte wenn es um stifte oder
und dynamik aus meter tiefen und bürger
ist der litauer
es geht nicht um so viel geld und aber
abgesagt umgekehrt ist doch so dass
trainer für die erbschaftssteuer wäre
das tier war ich sowieso nichts erwarten
sich leisten kann muss nicht klar dass
ich würde es komplett zu mir hatte die
erbschaftssteuer klopp stehen wir mit
einer frei machen für zwei millionen das
heißt die meisten
betroffen sondern wir hatten immer noch
schön schreiben damit nach aber ich
glaube es ist einfach immer die
hintergründige idee
und irgendwie im jura hinter noch einmal
großer hof oder mit 40 dollar und dan
net internet und da war dann auch immer
noch unter der zwei millionen stadt
liegt also ich weiß es nicht aber die
wir jetzt auch nicht eine
erbschaftssteuer spezialist tote lag
dann stimmt das ja es gab immer noch
viel brutaler zu und her wie beseitigen
wieso
diese komplizierte geschichte ich habe
mich heute nicht nur lebensgeschichte
verzeichnen sondern das ganze familien
sie stehe im eventuell kurz mehrere
generationen zurück jährlicher des
drucker ist uns komplett darauf muss man
auf zack und
christa haas ist die biblische stoffe
schlimm ist es was ich glaube das ist
schon amtlich
das ist für uns kompliziert ist flach
und direkt ohne umweg out und das einzig
interessante oder interessant rische bei
mir war das bayerischen zentren die
kinder auf der strecke geblieben das
bescheinigen ist dass immer die
komplizierten doch nicht so lustig für
komödien zugeeignet darüber dass privat
das geht an die institution aber wie zum
beispiel kunsthaus zürich wurde herrscht
jetzt die sammlung bührle zeigt die
kunstsammlung vom ehemaligen verhandlung
öffentlich zeigt was
also ist jeder weg die gesanglich und
wie soll man auch ein ich sehe aber mit
historisch zusammenhang in der sterbe-
und das muss stadt und kanton mache ja
es wird klar die emotionen kochen hoch
in den letzten wochen sei die sammlung
bührle im kunsthaus zürich eingezogen
ist über die frage ob genug getan wurde
um die herkunft der bilder aufzuklären
und vor allem auch transparenz zu machen
darüber wird nun heftig gestritten
das ist eine prachtvolle hülle das neue
zürcher kunsthaus und doch im kern sehr
belastet durch das erbe eines
kunstsammlers ihr einziger gekauft 1947
einmal sechs jahre davor
ein sisley wiederum 1947 und endkurve
[Musik]
diese bilder gingen durch jüdische hände
viele nicht alle haben ihre flucht vor
der nazis mit den bildern finanziert
um dann bei emil bührle zu landen
die frage die sich hier am kunsthaus
zürich beispielhaft zeigt ist wie geht
man um mit einem solchen erbe
die schweiz unterscheidet zwischen
bildern die den opfern von nazis geraubt
wurden und solchen die auf der flucht
aus notverkauft werden mussten
beides wird unterschiedlich gehandhabt
andrea russia ist experte für raubkunst
und berät auch opferfamilien er findet
das müsse sich ändern
[Musik]
berlin
gestorben
so ziehen die familie verkaufte nimmt
viel geld winkt das ist quatsch diese
situation aber nach dem beachtung der
staub versuchen weil sie führen mit
ihrer familie nahmen sie die bilder mit
und finanziert damit die flucht von
sichere tod das ich flucht gut und das
schließt und
kunst dass man sogar noch gut aber
eigentlich gar zum vorgänger
diskriminierung und
lucas glover ist seit 20 jahren direktor
der sammlung bührle immer wenn beide
eine rückgabeforderung im raum stand hat
er gekontert
sofort ein bild wie einfach der führende
kunst eigentlich vorsieht in new york
natürlich dachten sich
doch klar weiß die herkunft bei bio des
bildern ist sehr oft umstritten
[Musik]
dass die boni als kluge hätte in der
kette der vag doch es ist auch bekannt
dass man locker so oder anders kein
taktieren das ist
controversy sachen
kontrovers sicher doch nach langjähriger
forschung zieht lukas gloor auf der
sammlungs eigenen website ein anderes
fazit
es geht für viele vor unserer bilder
natürlich
finanzen moment können zog verfolger bis
zum anfang und denn im einzelfall
tatsächlich bilder schießen wo in der
20er jahre zum beispiel in roger
sammlung feststellt sie sind und vor dem
plötzlich in der schweiz auftauchen in
240 und das sind die volksseele warum
seid ihr vertieft also untersucher tor
vorbei ehe sie möglicherweise
problematische sie zu wechseln dahinter
muss in hütte ähnlich glücklich er
vertrage das im moment nach unserer
erkenntnis kein bild mehr in unsere
sammlung ist aber dass sie ihn immer
vorläufig aussage
auf diese aussagen der stiftung bühne
hat sich auch die stadt zürich verlassen
als es darum ging die sammlung ins
öffentlich finanzierte kunsthaus zu
überführen
[Musik]
das meinte die stadtpräsidentin noch
kurz vor der eröffnung
dass sie schnitt aufgabe vor der stadt
private sammlung
provenienzforschung
gold führen oder zu überwachen
nur da zeigt dass das
gemacht wofür der stiftung stellt
hier gehen die meinungen auseinander
guido magnaguagno ehemaliger vize
direktor des zürcher kunsthauses schrieb
schon 2015 dass die herkunft von
mindestens 30 bildern in der sammlung
nicht lupenrein nachgeprüft wurden also
einerseits etwas natürlich mit
profit daraus zu sehr günstigen preis
für meine einzige grund sparkurs kerth
der ex ja dass die seite und zu andere
ist das halt die provenienzforschung was
machte nur halber gott ist
sehr positives in anderen drei
vorhandenen träger und sie geht sehr
tief
ein beispiel ist die herkunft einer
schneelandschaft von gustave courbet
[Musik]
tatsächlich irgendwie auch zu 36 die
zweite ist 19 250 also in fast
hundertjährige und in zwei kisten
autokäufern des kunsthändlers in london
wo mitbürgers befindet sich unter die
sammlungen aufteilt also eine music and
end und also man ja klar wenn also bis
gesicht denkt na ja also jeder
kunsthändler also vorerst in die bildung
[Musik]
ein weiteres strittiges werk ist eine
landschaft von calls verkauft in den usa
von einer jüdischen witz für die vor den
nazis fliehen musste das bild ist
740 in den usa fordert sitze
durchmachten othman verkauft wurde in
der
folge stattfinden das ist eine ziemlich
gelassen ab wann geht der verkauf eines
bildes als not um zu überleben
manja guano kennt weitere schicksale
das bild ist am schluss vor dem fuß
verkauft worte von der doch doch
holstein wo in estoril kirche dem moment
also an dem ort um letzten ort wie
lissabon wo man könne über fahrt über
hoch wenn überhaupt oder wenn man wieder
über heute und das erkenne zahle dem
moment hat sie das bild
genau ja und das ist relativ klar dass
das
ist
offensichtlich hat emil bührle
profitiert davon dass die vorbesitzer
der bilder auf der flucht waren
so flucht gut bildlich in der sammlung
der e-mobilität die juwelen nicht der
einzelne besitzer abkaufte hätte immer
über das schweizer handel erworben und
es gibt keinen grund
dass du in deinem sinn also
veräußerung erfolgt sehen wo zu
ungunsten der verkäufer passiert lasse
das jetzt zum beispiel die verkäufe der
verkauf soll es gar nix hatte die
verkäufer hatten
massiv unter dem wert verkaufen die
verkäufer haben nach unserer
einschätzung
die freie entscheidung über den verkauf
bis zum schluss halten
wie frei kann man entscheiden auf der
flucht ohne geld wir wissen es heute
nicht mehr doch wie gehen wir damit um
bei der offiziellen stelle für raubkunst
beim bundesamt für kultur spricht man
von unfreiwilligen oder konfus
katholischen verkäufen die fair und
gerecht behandelt werden soll doch bei
solchen fällen fehlt es an einer
konkreten handhabe
[Musik]
ganz spezifisch überhaupt machen statt
diskriminiert und die früheren frau wird
freigelegt und der goldmarkt wirklich
sitzungsverlauf unsicheren renten und
das muss man aber genauer jetzt viele
interpretation was heißt fehlen
qualifizierte
der umgang mit heiklen bildern muss sich
ändern das hat das kunstmuseum bern
begriffen seit es die sammlung des
ehemaligen nazi kunsthändlers gurlitt
übernommen hat bilder die unter ns
verfolgungsbedingten umständen verkauft
oder verloren gingen werden genau
untersucht im zweifel wird an die erben
zurückgegeben
wenn es geht darum dass man
dass jetzt die fälle wo man schon sehr
lange vor sich herschieben museum so
viel dass mit jetzt michael haid vienna
und das mit ihr kleid mit ihrer
argumentation wo man
auch dazu stehen es wäre an der zeit
eine einheitliche lösung für alle museen
zu finden eine emotion fordert nun eine
nationale kommission die in
zweifelsfällen mindestens eine
empfehlung abgeben könnte
kommissionsempfehlung spricht damit das
übergeordnete objektiver verfahren kommt
und was dafür spricht dagegen und dann
kam die kommission in die ganze sache so
sie hat einen fehler gehen
[Musik]
in zürich liegt es nun auch am kunsthaus
nochmals über die bücher zu gehen und
die herkunft aller bilder der sammlung
bührle von einer unabhängigen stelle
prüfen zu lassen
es ist zu hoffen dass der tag kommen
wird das in allen museen der schweiz die
bilder hängen die rechtens sind
[Musik]
manche gesetze des mittelabschnitts über
oder her schon vorgezogen vor
betrügerischen rußpartikel vermutet das
ist nur vorbezug und tratsch tragen
jetzt vom lebensstil familien eltern
38 montag das ist aber gut
frage wie das ist mit dem er übernimmt
das gerecht ist wenn es gehöre zum
gehweg und dht hand eine wirklichkeit
ja es ist eine komplexe
jetzt noch darum was die autofahrer
übersehen bei grundsatz ist das problem
wenn die großen immer größer werden und
die klinik hat das geht eine möglichkeit
das ist schlacht das ist auf die große
firma geschlecht letztlich
gesamtgesellschaftlich einfacher schlaue
idee und du musst regel ein schaf ist
der zulieferer das mit einem doppel
stuttgart das ist presse auch gemeint
die lütow zu mir ist doch einmal
kommunalwahl klassischen verstörte gab
es während die verstehen ist enorm das
hatte ich gehe einfach mit der natur von
gestern aber dass man damit noch 46 euro
zu mir nach hinten also ich glaube man
muss das automatische aber pragmatisch
heißt es
ist doch so ein halber spezialist
von der see und im tagestief
ja wir haben es heute ja vom erben vom
großen geld das von der einen in die
nächste generation wechselt was aber
wenn jemand überhaupt kein interesse
daran hat am erben und am geld an sich
mein kollege milo gadient hat einen
jungen mann getroffen in zürich auf dem
genau das zutrifft
die höchste liga neben erich
lebenskünstler aktivist und der zeit man
kann leben ohne geld funktioniert das
ich bin skeptisch
er hat als gamedesigner gearbeitet
könnte bis zu 1000 franken pro tag
verdienen heute will er absichtlich
nicht mehr teil des arbeitsmarktes seien
[Musik]
ein weltverbesserer ein kapitalismus
kritiker der es ernst meint wie wir ihn
ist auch schon ohne geld nach barcelona
gepilgert und er hat zwei jahren
freiwillig und ganz bewusst auf der
straße gelebt
also man muss
hier schon los zum erstaunen der so groß
geld ausgeben für dieselbe
haye zu mir gekommen ist und ich merke
wird die sache wohl nicht können
sind das sind zum beispiel einfach genug
schlaf
das ist wirklich
sensationell meister womit wirklich
kostet
[Musik]
fokussieren
klingt eigentlich ganz gut aber gegessen
hat man von diesen gedanken auch noch
nicht denn da liegt gerade mein in den
fokus
[Applaus]
so einfach ist es nicht sich sein essen
zu besorgen ist denn auch einer seiner
alltäglichen hauptbeschäftigungen
zufälligerweise
die akteure die zuschläge
jetzt
erzählt seine haltung alles bewusst tun
mit viel achtsamkeit
[Musik]
wenn sie eines nicht gerade auf der
straße liegt rot er sich den großteil
seiner nahrung aus einer garten
kooperative das auf dauer aber recht
zahlen relativ viel ist wahrscheinlich
immer noch günstigen moment und wo kommt
das geld
genau das kommen von
verschiedenen liegt also vor gericht und
euch bekannt und wo mir vertraut oder
wohlstand liegen dass experimente
unterstützen was du würde ich eigentlich
alle medaillen viel mehr lernen dazu
einfach genial bisher weiter so ich
merke das ist mein weg zum zum die welt
mit dem offenen herz begegnen vielleicht
ist für brandis ist
wenn die person viel geld verdienen und
viel kann so großzügig
kochen und schlafen tut libyen derzeit
im haus seiner großmutter
er darf dort leben und muss keine miete
bezahlen
und die referent für woche von hyundai
nimmt ohne wohnung jetzt ruhen würde
mich echt sowas
kontrast zu der idee und was lieber ohne
geld nur voll
krass oder sonne viele naja so etwas ist
schluss aber du weißt du eben wenn wird
das alles dirk würde
wahrscheinlich also es wird sich sowie
zur besseren sind irgendwie sah 17 busse
und cousine bevor er sich an scherben
sowie
das wird dir passieren genau und ich
angeordnet dass jetzt das nicht will
also wir haben das bewusst sieht dass
ich einfach dass das ich kann danach und
die fahrt aufgenommen aber das
interessiert mich nicht so und
vielleicht
haben in diesem dilemma steckt der
lebens experimentierer drin aber
macht die tatsache dass er eigentlich
privilegiert ist seine idee weniger
glaubwürdig es ist eine art systemkritik
der an bringt aber auch der komfortzone
heraus
und dann
frage ich für nicht mehr wie
privilegiert
ist das utopisch egoistisch realistisch
reduziert und fokussiert ist libyens
lebensweise auf jeden fall und darum für
ihn scheinbar auch sinne führt
mehr
[Musik]
ja das war es von uns für heute zum
thema erben übrigens gibt es aktuell bei
111 kultur einen themenschwerpunkt mehr
dazu finden sie online mike müller geht
nun auf tournee mit seinem stück erbs
tag und ist hier in melas zürich auch
wieder zu sehen ab jahren war und wir
wir fragen nächste woche wie wollen wir
in zukunft reisen und gleich jetzt geht
ihr weiter auf sf1 mit der sternstunde
philosophie auch zum thema abend mit
einem streitgespräch eine gute woche für
siebtes
[Musik]
album sexy an
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]